commencer cette audition et vous
remercier Monsieur le Directeur Général
de votre présence et nous accueillons
donc monsieur Stanislas Bouron
aujourd'hui directeur général de
l'Agence nationale de la cohésion des
territoires dans la NCT a pour mission
de conseiller de soutenir les
collectivités territoriales dans la
conception la définition et la mise en
œuvre de leur projet à ce titre elle
doit notamment faciliter l'accès des
communes aux différentes formes
d'ingénierie juridique financières et
techniques et leur apporter un concours
financier et humain l'ambition est vaste
et pour le sujet qui nous occupe à une
pause plusieurs questions est-ce que la
NCT a aujourd'hui appris quelques
années de de jeunesse c'était encore une
agence très jeune a-t-elle aujourd'hui
les moyennes de cette ambition est-ce
qu'elle est parvenue à constituer un
réseau suffisamment efficace à
destination des communes l'aide qu'elle
peut leur apporter tel suffisamment
concrète
[Musique]
en matière
d'ingénierie singulièrement dans celle
des communes qui sont les moins dans ces
monts peuplées et qui ont par définition
et par nature le moins de moyens pour
répondre à cette politique d'appel à
projet de l'État mais pas simplement
tout simplement pour pour monter des des
projets communaux voire intercommunalité
intercommunaux pardon parce qu'on a
aussi des des intercommunalités qui ne
ruisselle pas de de moyens ou encore un
peu du mal à se repérer dans le meilleur
voilà mon propos dépasse un peu le seul
cadre de la NCT mais sur sur l'ensemble
de l'ingénierie d'État convaincu que
l'un des rôles qui étaient
dévolue à la NCT c'était un peu d'être
le à la fois le catalyseur et
c'était cet agence qui avait vocation
justement à répartir ou à répondre aux
aspirations des des élus alors par le
biais des opérations et des projets que
l'on connaît des dispositifs petites
villes de demain
un coeur de ville mais au-delà de ça on
voit bien que
parfois j'allais dire les mers sont un
peu démunies et l'idée d'avoir dans le
cadre de la loi 3DS fait du préfet de
département le délégué départemental
et on se faisait la réflexion encore
dernièrement n'est pas totalement
assimilé
et si j'osais je dirais même
assumer par par l'ensemble des des
acteurs des des préfets notamment ou des
sous-préfet parce qu'on a vu aussi que
certains dans certains départements
c'était des sous-préfet qui étaient
dédiés sur cette sur cette mission là
donc comment vous voyez cette cette
aspect là des des choses maintenant ça
fait un peu plus de de trois ans si je
ne m'abuse que que la NCT fonctionne
et on sent qu'il y a encore un besoin
d'identifier l'action de la N et
dernière dernière petite question
comment vous articuler dans la pratique
parce que là aussi on sent qu'il y a un
sujet entre
préfecture sous préfecture et l'agence
parce qu'on voit bien qu'il y a et il y
a parfois là encore un sujet et que
au-delà des dispositifs existants et on
l'avait évoqué avec vous même via le les
personnes qui sont financées les moyens
humains financés par l'État et un besoin
d'ingénierie qui dépasse ce cadre là et
qui j'allais dire mais en première ligne
les préfectures et les sous-préfectures
pour notamment leur agilité et leur
écoute vis-à-vis des élus voilà j'étais
beaucoup trop long pardon mais
merci beaucoup la présidente sur
rapporteur je peut-être dans quelques
mots pour répondre à ces premières
questions
d'abord effectivement l'agence est
relativement récente quand même à
l'horizon de nos systèmes administratifs
à la 3 années donc avec une gouvernance
renouvelé puis décembre avec nouveau
conseil d'administration de vos
présidents nos directeur général n'ont
pas que il y avait avant après mais il y
a forcément des évolutions et surtout
aussi trois années qui ont été marquées
par aussi une période qui était quand
même très compliqué pour tout le monde
en termes d'action publique notamment
une bonne année et demi de covid
nuisant on va dire les choses à l'équipe
en place pour faire ce que aujourd'hui
on est en train de faire avec le
Président c'est à dire se déplacer
beaucoup aussi sur le terrain et aller
voir aussi ce qui va ce qui va moins
bien comment les choses prennent donc je
reconnais que cette chance que nous
avons depuis maintenant le mois de
février où nous avons engagé avec le
président des déplacements nombreux on
est j'essaie de recompter mais une
petite vingtaine de départements déjà
visité
nous permet aussi de voir au plus près
les les points qui qui fonctionnent et
ce qui fonctionne moins bien
sur d'abord sur les missions de l'Agence
en deux mots pour que effectivement qui
est pas de quelque chose soit très clair
on a deux vocations que le législateur
nous a donné c'est un porter des
programmes nationaux
de être là on va dire en subsidiarité
pour accompagner les collectivités qui
ont besoin de trouver des solutions
d'ingénierie et puis on peut parler des
contractualisations mais c'est pas
vraiment le sujet aujourd'hui sur les
programmes nationaux vous avez cité à
réaction cœur de ville petit lieu demain
il y en a d'autres autour du numérique
par exemple aussi territoire industrie
et franc service
globalement je pense qu'on peut quand
même assez honnêtement dire que c'est
une réussite même si évidemment quand on
parle de petit guide de main 1600
communes et forcément il y en a pour qui
ça marche mieux que d'autres par la
force des choses mais globalement moi
les déplacements que je fais le retour
qu'on en a c'est que les choses se
passent bien pour tout vous dire même je
suis
très surpris encore de l'enthousiasme
qui que les élus nous renvoient
lorsqu'on les rencontre pour tout vous
dire même dans les premiers temps je me
suis dit mais c'est
c'est un peu un village totemkine qu'on
essaie de renvoyer les préfets et en
fait non à chaque déplacement on voit
des élus qui sont emparés en fait emparé
dans label de moyens d'une logique de
projet et qui ont su les prendre à leurs
mains et de façon très différente selon
les territoires c'est ce qui est
intéressant et on y reviendra après
parce que c'est vrai que la solidarité
elle est vraiment elle doit être la clé
d'entrée mais elle est aussi très
dépendante de ce qui existe sur les
territoires
on a vraiment des programmes qui ont
trouvé leur public
sur le volet ingénierie sur mesure
forcément les programmes on peut
considérer que si on sort le numérique
ou joint de 6000 communes mais qui est à
part sur la fibre sur tout ce qui
aimerait dire accompagnement de projet
on a 2000-2500 3000 communes qui que
l'on touche et puis si on sort les très
très grande qui sont pas forcément qu'on
touche à travers la politique de la
ville on a à peu près voilà 30 000
communes qui peuvent ne pas avoir un
programme dédié qui sont concernés par
des mesures autour de la ruralité mais
ils sont des mesures transversales
peut-être moins identifiables et qui du
coup peuvent être en attente
d'ingénierie d'accompagnement sur mesure
donc l'objet de l'agence c'est
intervenir pour permettre de défaire
émerger et porter leurs projets là où le
contexte local ne le permet pas donc là
aussi c'est vraiment je crois qu'il faut
qu'on soit c'est ce qui a pu rendre un
peu complexe exercice par le passé qu'il
reste toujours c'est que on n'a pas
vocation intervenir là où des
collectivités se sont organisées de
façon pertinente pour mettre en place
une solution d'ingénierie à travers une
agence technique départementale ainsi a
eu très dynamique une agence d'urbanisme
une intercommunalité qui a pris à bras
le corps telle ou tel sujet pas plus
tard que dans les Vosges vous étiez les
Vosges j'ai été il y a deux jours on a
visité une intercommunalité qui a mis en
œuvre tout un soutien de commune très
rurale ou l'État intervient mais dans du
cofinancement de poste et à travers
ensuite de l'allovation d'investissement
et ça se passe bien comme ça parce que
l'interco s'est emparé du sujet c'est
pas forcément le cas partout c'est vrai
donc en fait dans la capacité de
l'intérêt pour nous c'est de la
identifier les territoires où ce ne se
crée pas ou n'existe pas cette cette
dynamique on sait qu'il y a un tiers des
départements qui n'ont pas mis en place
d'agence départementale par exemple quel
qu'en soit le format établissement
public ou
régie parce que ça peut marcher en régie
aussi et puis même là où les agents
techniques des partenaires je le vois
elles peuvent être et c'est très utile
mais elles peuvent prioriser des sujets
type la voirie les équipements publics
ce qui est parfaitement indispensable là
aussi c'est très clair mais du coup
moins présente sur d'autres champs qui
appellent aussi un intérêt notamment la
réflexion sur le projet de territoire ou
ce genre de choses donc c'est là où
effectivement nous notre accompagnement
sur mesure il doit continuer à être
déployé aujourd'hui on a 1200
accompagnements qui ont été réalisés
depuis la création de l'agence mais on a
une nouvelle étape à engager donc à la
suite du rapport produit par la
délégation collectivité territoriale au
mois de février qui prévoyait un certain
nombre de préconisations on a commencé à
mettre en place un plan d'action qui
sera concrétisé et rappelé dans une
feuille de route que nous présenterons
au conseil d'administration à la fin du
mois de juin
aux administrateurs il y aura une
réunion préalable avec les
administrateurs élus pour leur présenter
le contenu donc je peux pas tout
dévoiler mais disons que moi sur
quelques aspects qui ont déjà fait
l'occasion l'objet d'une communication
dire qu'on vous rejoint sur l'idée qu'il
faut qu'on soit aussi plus en animation
des territoires parce qu'il y a des
endroits on nous connaît très très bien
et on sait à faire appel à nous c'est
dans le Cantal dans le Cantal il y a pas
un des dispositifs de l'agence qui n'est
pas mis en oeuvre pas 1 qui est
aujourd'hui mobilisé et parfois même
dans le même site sur une commune qui
est PVD qui a un tira lieu qui inconcier
numérique qui a un franc service et qui
sait utiliser notre accompagnement sur
mesure donc c'est voilà on est sur des
très grands été ré hétérogénéité pardon
lié aussi au fait que l'agence est
encore récente qui est tout un travail
d'animation à poursuivre donc on doit
doubler nos moyens d'accompagnement des
préfets pour avoir vraiment une
proximité plus forte des chargées de
mission territoriaux qui soient vraiment
sollicitables à
donc tant qu'il est possible par les
préfets ou les DDT
on doit nous aussi on y réfléchit
avancer sur une déconcentration du
marché de notre marché d'ingénierie pour
permettre qu'il soit plus facilement
mobilisable par les préfets départements
sans passer par une sollicitation
parisienne donc là aussi logique de de
donner de la souplesse et puis on doit
travailler à une meilleure animation
locale de des équipes d'ingénierie et
des demandes ce que je constate moi
c'est que on a effectivement certains de
projets qui trouvent pas forcément leur
chemin leur réponse et maintenant
souvent de petites communes petites
interconnalités et qui ont du mal à
trouver voilà la réponse
qui pourrait exister par ailleurs donc
on doit notre objectif c'est d'essayer à
travers les comités de cohésion
territoriale qui sont prévues par la loi
créant l'agence qui dans certains
départements fonctionnent plutôt très
bien être des lieux d'animation sur
faire connaître l'étude d'ingénierie le
cas échéant discuté sur qui peut se
mobiliser sur tel et telle thématique
parce que c'est intéressant on voit que
par exemple sur la technique sont
souvent ingénierie opérationnels très
utiles pour mettre en oeuvre des projets
pour qu'ils se concrétisent on voit
qu'on a aussi qu'on peut faire venir le
serema sur des objets type sur les
mobilités sur les sols de la question de
foncier et puis on voit que non pas
intervenir typiquement régulièrement sur
les questions d'activité commerciale sur
des questions touristiques sur la
question de projet de territoire donc en
fait cette capacité à mettre en lien les
différents outils donc ce comité local
c'est un bel espace qu'il faut qu'on
m'encourage et les ministres souhaitent
et c'est aussi sans doute renforcer
cette logique de guichet unique à
travers la capacité à
beaucoup de départements enfin un
certain nombre ont mis en place une
adresse mail unique c'est tout bête mais
ça marche très bien c'est à dire que
l'élu qui a un projet ou un doute enfin
un accompagnement qu'il souhaite
il écrit à cette adresse et il est sûr
d'avoir une réponse derrière qui sera
faite par un référent peut être un
sous-préfet d'arrondissement le DDT peu
importe à la limite le sujet c'est
localement comment ça s'organise faut
laisser les gens intelligemment apporter
une réponse d'organisation mais il faut
que à chaque question il y est une
réponse qui est pas forcément de dire on
va déployer une étude très compliquée
mais au moins de dire voilà le chemin
voilà comment on peut faire donc c'est
cette logique de portail puisque de
guichet parce que guichet ça fait très
peur a beaucoup d'acteurs qui disent il
y aura un endroit on va décider à notre
place non c'est un point d'entrée en
fait il faut qu'on arrive à améliorer le
point d'entrée pour pour les élus qui
sont peut-être les plus éloignés de
l'information
on a aussi un rôle
de d'arriver à mieux organiser et que je
vous disais à travers le clct mieux
organisé ce qui existe sur le terrain
souvent il y a beaucoup d'acteurs déjà
présents et qui
voilà ce sont pas forcément actionnés ou
mobilisés alors qu'il y a un projet qui
est dans lesquels il pourrait intervenir
donc nous on est prêt à intervenir bien
sûr si besoin et s'il n'y a pas de
solution mais l'idée c'est pas d'aller
chercher l'agence s'il y a une solution
locale comme je vous le disais il faut
vraiment qu'on soit en musique de
subilité on n'est pas dans la
concurrence entre type d'ingénierie
donc concrètement sur le notre objectif
pour nous dans les dans les mois à venir
c'est d'arriver donc je vous le disais à
mieux organiser ce portail d'accès sur
l'ensemble des outils d'ingénierie à
revoir nos conventions notamment avec
les cinq opérateurs principalement sur
nos sujets Adem et cérémy qui sont des
gros acteurs d'ingénierie public pour
aussi clarifier le type d'ingénieur
offert par chacun de façon à ce que pour
les délégués territoriaux et pour les
élus ce soit plus simple aussi de savoir
qui fait quoi non c'est simplement après
ça restera toujours il y aura peut-être
beaucoup de position mais au moins on
sera mieux sur quel quel sujet vers qui
on doit se tourner une fois qu'on a
saisi éventuellement le préfet ou sous
préfet et puis là aussi cet
accompagnement j'ai indiqué à travers
des moyens humains qu'on est en train de
recruter pour mettre au moins une à deux
personnes pour les grandes régions 2
pour les plus petites peut-être qu'une
seule en interface directe avec les
préfets de départements pour aller sur
le terrain et puis venir conseiller sur
comment je monte mon projet comment je
dois procéder et quel type d'ingénierie
je peux solliciter
sur la mobilisation des délégués
territoriaux
je vous rejoins sur le fait que elle
n'est pas uniforme
je pense qu'il y a une explication aussi
c'est que il y a des territoires qui en
ressentent plus ou moins enfin qui sont
plus ou moins mobilisés par ces
questions et par ses problématiques
c'est tout le
tous les territoires ne sont pas en même
difficulté par rapport à ces questions
en tout cas c'est pas uniforme dans les
départements moi j'ai pu me rendre je
sens quand même une grande mobilisation
des services pour nous reciter je
changerai après mais par exemple le
Cantal il y a deux agents de la DDT qui
ont dédiés exclusivement au projet et
aux accompagnements de l'agence
nationale la cohésion des territoires
et qui ont même pu développer des
accompagnements au-delà même de communes
qui aujourd'hui sont dans nos programmes
dans tous les départements je me suis
rendu on trouve des référents peut-être
parfois suffisamment équipés armés parce
que face à au nombre de projets mais qui
se sont organisés pour essayer
d'apporter des réponses évidemment
Charles à nous d'être encore plus
volontariste vis-à-vis d'eux pour leur
demander effectivement de s'investir
toujours plus
et de façon plus uniforme parce que je
vous rejoins il y a une hétérogénéité
selon aussi une histoire et un passé
d'organisation locale
juste si vous le permettez pour réagir à
cela en réalité je vais être un petit
peu trivial mais au fond la conclusion
que l'on tire des échanges que l'on peut
avoir dans les différents territoires
avec les élus c'est peut nous importe à
quoi ressemble finalement
cet architecture qui consiste à traiter
de la question de l'ingénierie là où on
a le sentiment que le bât blesse c'est
que je prends un exemple très concret
pour que mon propos soit bien compris
s'agissant notamment de petites villes
de demain
on a plutôt le sentiment que s'agissant
de l'ingénierie à savoir le poste qui
est financé par l'État ça fonctionne
globalement plutôt bien là où il y a une
vraie frustration c'est qu'une fois que
le projet est échafaudé qui commence
dans les concours les contours par avant
commencer à être défini il y a le sujet
de la pré et des financements et comment
on réussit et en réalité
ce que voudrait les élus je vais le dire
de façon très directe c'est un package
qui irait de cette boîte mail que vous
aimez ou ou d'un contact avec un préfet
un sous-préfet et de dire après on a le
moyen on fait l'ingénierie charge à vous
de faire cette animation c'est ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure pour qu'on est
aussi la perspective d'avoir des
financements qui permettront la
réalisation du du projet et là on sent
bien qu'il y a une coupure une césure
qui est quand même
vécue comme une frust c'est à dire que
on sait faire émerger les projets on
sait on sait les les montées dans la
plupart des cas mais après voilà et ça
c'est globalement ce que de façon
unanime nous ont dit nous ont dit les
élus et le deuxième sujet c'est sur les
plus petites communes c'est ce que vous
disiez le recours céréma le recours où
on sent bien que là il y a il y a un
flou qui persistait faire le lien avec
une audition que nous avons eu ce matin
avec le dmat qui nous disait que l'État
s'apprêtait à recruter entre guillemets
des des experts une centaine de de
d'agents un peu un peu expert voir
comment tout ça peut s'articuler parce
qu'encore une fois on a le sentiment qui
a aussi sur la forme quelque chose à
trouver en matière déficience et en gros
d'accélération des process
justement dans le même ordre d'idées que
ce que vient d'écrire Mathieu il y a un
exemple aussi qui a été qui est récent
sur la non continuité un certain moment
de de l'action de l'anxiété qui a la
base était intéressante c'était le
programme pont alors bon je pense que ça
va évoluer peut-être parce que j'ai eu
quelques informations par le préfet des
Hautes-Pyrénées mais ce programme pont
où on a proposé par un appel à projet
aux communes de solliciter l'ingénierie
pour
surveiller ou analyser leur les dégâts
sur leurs ouvrages d'art et où ils ont
reçu des fiches techniques des
diagnostics avec des préconisations
qu'ils ont prises la plupart du temps et
où là on a une espèce de flottement
entre le moment où on doit aller
chercher de la maîtrise d'oeuvre pour
réaliser des bureaux d'études pour
réaliser les compléments de de
d'informations sur ces ouvrages et
ensuite le fil à la question du
financement derrière parce qu'un certain
moment la DETR n'intervenait pas sur les
ponts et les ouvrages d'art donc voilà
donc il y a une il y a une vraie une
vraie enjeux là pour les communes de de
continuité dans l'action et dans les
plans d'action qui sont menées qui sont
à la base plus intéressant parce que sur
le département des Hautes-Pyrénées le
programme pont je crois qu'il y a plus
de 200 communes qui ont répondu donc
c'est un vrai succès ça répondait un
vrai besoin voilà mais il faut pas
certainement sans mauvais jeu de mots
les laisser au milieu du gué
que que les propos du rapporterait de la
présidente
vous avez évoqué votre déplacement sur
les départements et l'engouement des
élus que vous rencontrez autour
notamment du programme petite ville de
demain
je vais dire très sincèrement d'abord
les élus sont des gens bien élevés donc
en fait quand il vous reçoivent dire
priori vous leur apportez pas du mal et
donc ils sont plutôt bienveillants je
préfère le dire voilà avec un peu
d'ironie permettrait je veux le dire je
crois que beaucoup dans les
bénéficiaires de petites villes de
demain sont satisfaits et c'est pour ça
je vais reprendre quand vous dites
qu'ils sont enjoués en parce que
ils sont satisfaits d'une chose en tout
cas moi le retour que j'ai dans le
département de la Loire c'est que ça
leur permet dans ces temps et peut-être
encore plus aujourd'hui hier où il faut
aller vite où il faut faire tout tout de
suite maintenant
quelque part d'être retenu à petite
ville de demain ça les oblige et ça je
mets ça leur permet
la question n'est pas de se défausser
mais ça leur permet compris au regard de
leur population de justifier qu'on va
prendre du temps pour s'interroger ce
que sera notre territoire demain ce que
sera notre village notre petite ville
demain et la place qu'elle aura dans son
environnement et que en fait
excusez-moi je vais vous le dire ainsi
mais intellectuellement
c'est assez jouissif et des moments
comme ça dans nos vies d'élus on en a
très peu et là quelque part voilà donc
il y a un atout qui permet alors à des
nouveaux élus de se projeter à des élus
avec plus d'expérience soudainement de
eux-mêmes de s'orienter et très
sincèrement moi il me l'ont dit et il me
disent ils me disent mais tu ne te rends
pas compte Cécile ça nous fait du bien
parce que quelque part on aimerait et là
comme on y obligé on le fait et on prend
plaisir mais je vais venir voilà et moi
je vous avais que quand vous voulez mais
après on fait un débrief abattons rompus
tout le monde enlève les casquettes
parce que moi je veux aussi vous
entendiez ces mêmes élus qui disent et
c'est les mêmes qui me disent ça qui me
disent ouais mais en même temps moi
Cécile j'ai passé l'âge qu'on vende des
rêves
et donc
travailler pendant un an comme j'ai
c'est super bien intellectuellement ça
peut être très jouissif ça peut être
très fédérateur à l'échelle d'un
territoire communal tout ça d'accord
mais en vrai si à la fin il y a rien qui
débouche ben on peut aussi générer des
déceptions des frustrations
pour pas aller plus loin si on n'a pas
les financements et du coup ce qui amène
à une deuxième difficulté territoriale
qui est qu'il ne faudrait pas demain
alors on y va et collectivement jusqu'au
jour où ça ça dérape que infinie un
certain nombre de financement
territorialisé notamment de l'État dans
un premier temps mais qui demain
pourrait être suivi qui par une
collectivité régionale qui parle une
collectivité départementale soit sous
forme de bonus soit sous forme de
priorité qui vise finalement à
concentrer les financements
territorialisés uniquement sur les
projets qui auront été en priorité qui
auront bénéficié pardon en priorité de
ce type d'ingénierie et ça c'est une
vraie crainte vous avez donc à la fois
une double crainte des élus qui est de
dire moi comment je vais financer
ce truc génial qu'on vient de faire au
bout d'un an et demi tous ensemble
comment je vais financer ce qu'on est en
train de faire voilà selon le temps où
on en est et le moment où on a été élu
et pour autant je ne veux pas être le
réceptacle des financements possibles et
de fragiliser les autres collègues des
autres communes parce que plus souvent
voilà donc je le prends c'est moins vrai
me semble-t-il en tout cas là encore à
l'échelle c'est très empire avec ce que
je dis donc voilà je n'en tire pas de
conclusion il me semble que c'est moins
vrai pour cœur de ville parce que là on
a des vrais financements etc qui vont
sur n'accompagnement et on sait aller
tirer bien quoi d'abord on a des
financements fléchés puis on sait aller
tirer aussi d'autres types de
financement où on n'est pas dans les
mêmes logiques donc on a moins ce
décalage mais mais moi vraiment
j'aimerais voilà qu'on essaie
discussions vraiment un bâton rompu et
compris ou peut-être nous et c'est pas
du tout
un péché d'orgueil que de dire cela est
compris nous de dire Homer non mais
allez-y maintenant on va se parler
franchement c'est que tu as le droit de
dire que ça ça va que ça ça passe ça
veut pas dire que demain tu seras
sanctionné que tu auras pas ta lettre
d'où tu l'aide parce qu'il y a toujours
un peu aussi cette crainte là donc voilà
comment est-ce que vous vous voyez ça
comme comment on construit on construit
ce demain et puis pour les plus petites
communes
oui bien sûr elles ont tous les droits
de tirage et moi j'entends souvent le
préfet sous préfet y compris me dire non
mais vous inquiétez pas on va on va les
accompagner objectivement c'est dur
voilà souvent ça ressemble quoi je pense
que les gars on leur dirait tu vas
gravir l'ivresse à mon avis il y en a
c'est plus facile de gravir les restes
enfin non moi je vous dis voilà moi j'ai
une commune 400 habitants ils ont un
problème de trucs de chemin à faire il y
a le céréma ils ont écrit trois trucs
contradicts quoi moi que joli comme
étant contradictoire on va les aider
mais en fait plus personne ne sait
comment aider et est-ce qu'à un moment
donné la NCT ne pourrait pas être aussi
une forme de facilitateur de tous ces
parce qu'on a besoin de gens spécialisés
ouais on peut pas être dans de la
polyvalence à toi donc à un moment on
aura des sujets et des champs
d'intervention de l'aménagement du
territoire qui qui doivent se
spécialiser est-ce qu'à une cité avec la
preuve ne sont pas une simple porte
d'entrée on arrête de de
casser les
à dire non mais il faut s'adresser là il
faut s'adresser à là il faut s'adresser
là on prend à votre problème et en fait
ouais votre problème de la Watch chemin
de fer du siècle dernier ou de toute
façon il y a déjà tout le train qui
roule il y en aura plus jamais mais en
même temps ça pouvait plus rien faire il
faut faire
aujourd'hui ça devient compliqué et il
me semble que voilà en matière
d'ingénierie et là c'est pas qu'une
question même si je vous rejoins sur
l'anesthétique les départements se
saisissent de cela y compris ce que
c'est une compétence à mon avis
fondamentale pour leur existence demain
et pertinente et ce sera pas simplement
à l'échelle d'agence technique
départementale et vous on sait tous y
compris de l'incapacité courant certain
département apporter ça voilà comment
est-ce qu'on on arrive de façon un peu
plus souple en tout cas à répondre
effectivement à la préoccupation de de
l'élu qui après tout se fiche de savoir
qui interpellait tant qu'on peut lui
régler la réponse
je vous avais dit des choses très
positives qui veut dire que il y a aussi
des voilà on partage aussi des retours
et des interrogations qui sont
d'ailleurs vous l'avez évoqué sur la
pluraluité des engagements qui viennent
aujourd'hui sur les sujets peut-être PVD
d'abord dire effectivement
qu'aujourd'hui on a 904 chefs de projets
qui ont été qui sont aujourd'hui sur le
terrain cofinancer à 75%
qui sont pour à peu près les deux tiers
dans des intercommunalités c'est qui
peuvent travailler pour plusieurs et
puis pour un tiers qui sont soit dans
des Petr des pays des PNR dans des
communes plutôt majoritairement ce qui
n'empêche pas qu'ils travaillent parfois
dans une commune pour deux communes ça
ils peuvent se partager
donc on a des on a aujourd'hui le
maillage quasiment bouclé il reste un
peu outre-mer on n'a pas de il y a
quelques chefs de projets qui sont pas
encore être recrutés et presque un
département métropolitain sur laquelle
reste encore des difficultés donc dans
tous les cas moi je vous rejoins
l'ingénierie en fait il y a deux aspects
il y a l'aspect on a besoin d'avoir et
c'est tout le sujet des petites toutes
petites commune d'avoir une force de
aider les élus à formaliser à préparer
le volet un peu administratif à mettre
en interface avec des bons
interlocuteurs à faire tout un travail
d'accompagnement notamment dans les
communes on va dire pas les plus grandes
etc et puis dans les plus grandes il y a
besoin d'une ingénierie plus technique
pour aller travailler sur des sujets
urbanismes aménagement plus complexes
qui passait V mais en tous les cas sur
les PVD on a besoin de chef de projets
qui soient une force de frappe
permanente en accompagnement des
services communaux intercommunaux
lorsqu'ils existent mais souvent assez
modestes et qui joue ce rôle d'animateur
permanent et ce rôle clairement dans
beaucoup de territoires ça marche très
bien
donc on a cette dimension là et avec du
coup l'émergence de de plans d'action
qui commence à apparaître avec un centre
d'opération et moi je vous rejoins mille
fois ça donne du temps et de la capacité
à se projeter sur un plan d'action
construit en faisant jouer des
différents leviers un des gros sujets
qui revient typiquement c'est le sujet
d'habitat des problématiques de logement
vacants dans les centres bourgs dans les
centres-villes qui sont des objets
complexes sur lesquels en fait c'est pas
simplement d'avoir une solution de terre
qui règle le problème il faut avoir être
capacité d'intervenir avec d'autres
acteurs trouver des maîtres d'ouvrage
faire jouer les objets des sujets
juridiques autour de
l'extropriation du des biens des biens
sans mettre plusieurs volets parfois
c'est simplement savoir mobiliser
pertinemment Lana avec les Dino paseru
booster qui permet effectivement s'il y
a des propriétaires bailleurs qui sont
intéressés d'avancer donc on voit
typiquement sur ce sujet on a des sujets
complexes et ça il faut du temps pour
arriver à faire un programme d'action et
le déployer ensuite avec persévérance et
avec des moyens en support donc ce chef
de projet c'est indispensable c'est ce
qui fait que l'élu peut trouver la
partie administrative de soutien et puis
il y a les ingénieries spécifiques que
vous évoquez sur les chutes très
complexes c'est vrai dans PVD c'est vrai
aussi non c'est vrai dans toutes les
communes il y a des choses très
spécifiques qui sont pas qui est
justifient pas de recruter quelqu'un à
temps plein pendant des mois qui
justifie un intervention dédiée Serena
Adam nous à travers le marché ou à
travers des études peu importe et ça
c'est vraiment un besoin qui vient en
plus et sur typiquement nous on
intervient par exemple dans une PVD
assez systématiquement en plus du chef
de projet pour soutenir réfléchir sur le
devenir d'une friche réfléchir sur un
aménagement complexe sur une centralité
qui n'est pas évidente pour arriver
aussi à ce que les élus puissent se
prendre un peu le temps du projet et
d'un projet plus réelle cohérent
donc ça c'est l'élément je pense
vraiment la plus-value qui qui
aujourd'hui apparaît assez vers montrer
l'exemple avec des communes plus
structurées des agglos aujourd'hui on le
voit ça prend corps avec PVD des
communautés de communes
puis à l'investissement alors
aujourd'hui comment ça apparaître c'est
plutôt bon signe l'idée que on a des
projets qui vont se déployer alors
d'abord le programme PVD il fait l'objet
tout comme SD vous savez c'était les 5
milliards qui sont devenus 6 dans la
nouvelle génération avec la nappe donc
des territoires actions logements et
l'État sur PVD c'est 3 milliards
d'objectifs à l'horizon 2026 on n'est
pas loin du milliard déjà consommé on a
les chiffres qui sont des dotations
d'investissement de l'état de Lana qui
intervient massivement au titre des opas
mais aussi d'autres outils et puis la
banque des territoires
donc on a on a une enveloppe qui est pas
la même mais des projets qui sont pas
exactement les mêmes non plus
concrètement donc aujourd'hui la
question c'est est-ce que effectivement
tous les projets qui vont émerger
connaître trouveront leurs solutions
évidemment
moins à l'instant je vous parle je dis
bien à l'instant je vous parle je n'ai
pas eu de remonter dans les départements
de mer qui méditent un projet qui s'est
vu refusé sa subvention je dis pas que
ça pourrait pas arriver à un projet
prévu dans PVD qui a été validé qui rend
dans le projet je dis pas il y a que la
montée en puissance ce sujet va pas se
poser on a quand même l'arrivée du fond
vert qui rajoute 2 milliards d'euros de
subventions d'État on a aussi une
attention forte des départements des
régions maintenant sur ces dispositifs
bon voilà il y a quand même des moyens
d'accompagnement je vous rejoins aussi
sur un point complètement il faut
surtout éviter l'idée que un programme
préempte les moyens en dotation
d'investissement des autres je pense que
ça c'est désastreux et si on en voit
l'image que si on est je sais mais mais
vous pourrez je suis une grande
constance dans mes fonctions historiques
y compris il y a pas longtemps quand on
m'a dit dans un département on veut une
enveloppe PVD à part alors j'ai dit mais
elle est prise dans la DETR alors on me
répondait plus et clairement vous voyez
le problème
pour nous et les circulaires signées par
les ministres disent on priorise non pas
priori on rend exclusif on priorise des
projets qui qui sont cohérents parce
qu'accompagner dans le temps en temps
dans un projet de territoire donc
typiquement des projets type PVD mais ça
fait pas tout les montants dans la
réalité on est sur 200 à 300 millions
d'euros dotation d'investissement par an
sur ces communes là c'est pas la
totalité puisqu'on est à 2 milliards
hors fond vert donc pour l'instant on
n'est pas à capter la totalité des
moyens loin sans faux mais il y aura une
montée en puissance et cette question
effectivement si elle devait amener une
conclusion pour ce qui me concerne dans
mes fonctions c'est qu'il faut pas que
nous fassions d'investissement telle
qu'elle existe aujourd'hui baisse parce
que sinon on comprendrait pas c'est
effectivement c'est pas au moment où on
va avoir la montée en puissance ce qu'il
faut commencer à faire des efforts de
compression ou de mettre des outils deux
outils en un qui à la fin font moins que
deux parce que on connaît un peu la
méthode qu'on a pu voilà donc il y a des
outils qui ont leur vocation et qui
notamment par exemple là de terre très
investis qui fonctionne bien mais aussi
la des cils le fond vert qui chacun
leurs objets et qui sont bien
mobilisables au niveau de chaque
département par les préfets donc moi je
trouve que cette sujet de plurauité
c'est globalement une question lourde
aujourd'hui pour l'État et ses
opérateurs notamment sur
l'investissement c'est comment d'en
avoir des engagements dans le temps sans
créer une sorte de droit tirage parce
qu'il faut quand il y ait un projet qui
correspond aux objectifs bien sûr et
puis qui soit monté dans le cas d'un
plan d'action que vous disiez cohérent
je donne du temps réfléchi à comment on
travaille sur la commune et honnêtement
aujourd'hui il y a des endroits où ça a
marché moi j'ai vu quelques communes où
ils ont ils avaient démarré un peu avant
PVD parce qu'ils avaient déjà cette
dynamique locale ils s'en sont emparés
et j'ai vu des vraies réalisations
concrètes donc c'est c'est pas tout ça
n'est pas un mythe on pourrait
si vous le souhaitez on peut vous donner
des exemples de choses qui ont été mis
en oeuvre par les élus si c'est eux mais
Jean du chef de projet jouant du
partenariat local de l'effet un peu zoom
dont il bénéficie sur le territoire ils
ont réussi plein de choses des choses
variées comme reconquérir des des
logements de très mauvaise qualité en
coeur de vie pour les retransformer
traiter une friche créer un équipement
public à tel endroit donc ils ont fait
des choses sur les communes rurales plus
petites celles qui sont pas dans ces
dispositifs que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure
je rejoins sur un point c'est qu'au-delà
du guichet d'entrée qui permet de
faciliter d'explication du partenariat
local qui qui doit être animée il y a
quand même un sujet c'est que si on va
accompagner souvent une commune
toute petite centralité ou de 500 000
habitants parfois même la définition du
projet et l'accompagnement sans que ce
soit l'Everest simplement de notre
système il est pas simple forcément à
mobiliser souvent il y a qu'un
secrétaire de mairie pas forcément à
temps plein il y a des élus bonne
volonté mais pas toujours très à l'aise
avec ces arcanes du système et ce que
vous évoquez le débat ce matin c'est la
réflexion du programme France ruralité
qui est tiré en fait un peu d'expérience
de ce qu'on a pratiqué là qui est de
dire on a besoin d'avoir les chefs de
projet dont je parlais qui marche sur
les territoires qui soient aussi en
accompagnement pour ces communes on n'a
pas besoin de un par commune parce que
d'abord on va pas recruter 30000
personnes et que par ailleurs ça ne se
justifie pas on peut mutualiser on voit
déjà dans PVD on peut mutualiser et les
gens sont quand même occupés et donc
d'avoir quelqu'un qui puisse en appui
de certain nombre de communes leur
apporter ce travail d'information de
formalisation de mise en relation de
préparation des dossiers des cahiers des
charges le cas des champs pour les
marchés d'ingénierie financière on va
dire technique et puis d'identifier les
mettre d'ouvrages qui peuvent aussi
mettre en oeuvre éventuellement le
projet quand on est sur de l'habitat ça
peut être un bailleur social ça peut
être éventuellement la qui achètent et
puis qui ensuite fait les travaux il y a
différentes solutions donc ça c'est
typiquement l'objet de ce programme avec
l'idée de positionner des renforts et
renforts là dans les services de l'État
c'est ce qui évoqué le des maths ce
matin bon et avec donc des moyens qui
soit ensuite anti-rages par les
collectivités c'est vraiment pour les
collectivités c'est pas pour pas pour
l'État mais permettons aussi dans son
positionnement de facilité
l'articulation avec des DT avec nous
pour que ce soit du Sud proximité comme
les sujets plus compliqués sur lesquels
on interviendra
j'ai une question si vous me permettez
peut-être de nature plus
organisationnelle à défaut d'être
presque philosophiques s'agissant de
l'organisation de l'État sur les
territoires et
c'est autant le directeur de la NCT que
l'ancien DGCL que j'interroge sur cette
sur cette question est-ce que selon vous
j'ai quand même le sentiment et ce qui
me fait dire ça c'est que en ce moment
on parle beaucoup du fond vert
j'ai une question sur le fait
de considérer que cette politique à la
fois
d'agenceification et d'appels à projet
je le disais tout à l'heure
est-ce qu'elle ne segmente pas trop
la politique de l'État la
territorialisation si j'osais de
l'action publique et donc le rôle de
l'État sur sur le territoire est-ce
qu'elle ne l'a complexifie pas trop
parce qu'au fond et c'est une réflexion
et j'ai un souvenir d'un longue échange
que nous avions eu sur la question de la
notification de la décile préférée de
région versus préfet département l'âme
jambon était était présente et
finalement pour atterrir sur quelque
chose d'un peu hybride mais au fond si
on revient à l'objet premier est-ce que
et je vais le dire de façon très
schématique et totalement imparfaite
mais est-ce que si
le délégué départemental de la NCT le
préfet le sous-préfet avait une
enveloppe
quitte à ce que cette enveloppe
à l'instar de ce qui est fait sur la
DETR elle elle soit définie dans
l'octroi des subventions par une liste
de critères et une grille d'éligibilité
mais j'ai quand même le sentiment que à
chaque dotation ces modalités
d'attribution DETR des cils maintenant
fond vert que tout ça devient gentiment
et progressivement un peu un labyrinthe
un parcours du combattant pour pour
l'élu
puisqu'on a en plus la problématique de
l'ingénierie y aurait-il pas à mener une
réflexion pour j'allais dire peut-être
avoir une
j'allais dire une approche qui soit
territoriée avec le préfet la NCT à
l'échelle d'un département ce qui
permettrait aussi parce que c'est un
point qu'on évoque pas suffisamment
selon moi de prendre en compte le
critère de différentiation et on le voit
d'ailleurs dans la DETR ici on prend
plutôt l'eau que la voirie ailleurs
voilà donc chaque territoire à sa propre
réalité sa propre vérité et peut-être
que l'action de l'État
gagnerait aussi en lisibilité en
efficience à être défini à l'échelle
d'un territoire le département me paraît
de cette cette bonne échelle qui est à
la fois en proximité et qui permet de
vraiment prendre la bonne dimension des
des projets des problématiques et donc à
peut-être fondre un petit peu tout ça
pour le rendre pour le rendre plus
lisible et j'ajoute parce que c'est un
mot que j'aime bien plus agile parce
qu'on a quand même le sentiment même si
et je souscris vraiment ce qui a été dit
c'est à dire que sur l'ingén on voit que
les choses avancent mais voilà on voit
encore que des fois tout ça reste très
complexe et en regroupant en fusionnant
tout en gardant une lisibilité on est
bien d'accord que tout ne peut pas être
éligible que tout ne peut pas rentrer
dans une enveloppe mais il y a quand
même voilà j'ai évoqué cet exemple de la
décile parce que pour moi illustre
parfois le sentiment qu'au sein même de
l'État entre les champs régional
l'échelons départementales il y a quand
même une petite perte en ligne nous
évoquions tout à l'heure avec notre
présidente question du fond de
développement de la vie associative
voilà c'est un autre des exemples qui
montrent qu'on pourrait peut-être faire
des gains déficiences voilà et disons ça
je
la critique
ne s'adresse pas qu'à l'état on peut
aussi avoir une réflexion au niveau des
collectivités pour que là encore il est
quand même une cohérence et peut-être un
peu plus d'échanges on l'évoquait avec
le débat de ce matin pour mieux
appréhender le financement des projets
de l'ingén ierie jusqu'à la réalisation
c'est pareil avec votre ancienne et
votre nouvelle casquette
bien
je crois qu'on se connaît les uns les
autres donc on peut aussi se parler
sincèrement vous savez je suis très
attachée mais comme d'autres
à une présence de l'État au plus près de
chacun dans tous les territoires parce
que c'est la garantie d'une égalité
sociale et territoriale et j'ai envie de
dire dans les quatre coins de la
République que ce soit un territoire
rural que soit on est territoires
d'outre-mer que ce soit dans les
quartiers politiques de la ville je n'ai
aucun souci pour que l'on dise qu'il y
ait besoin alors je ne sais pas c'est
plus d'État au moins d'État mais qu'en
tout cas on a besoin d'une présence de
l'État aux côtés de tous ces territoires
qui font plus de 15 millions de de nos
concitoyens y compris quoi donc c'est
c'est un vrai enjeu et je crois dans la
France
je ne reviens pas parce que je partage
ce qu'a dit le rapporteur bon on peut
s'interroger est-ce qu'il fallait
agenciser cette action cette présence de
l'État au plus près de nos territoires
est-ce qu'il fallait
renforcer le rôle des de la présence des
départementales préfectoral préfectoral
sous-préfectorale j'ai envie de dire bon
il est législateur on tranchait bon j'ai
une question à vous poser mais vous avez
le droit de me dire qu'elle est
complètement hors sujet que vous ne
voulez pas y répondre ou que vous ne
voulez pas y répondre bon je n'ai pas
fait et je n'ai pas suivi les débats de
la loi de 2010 de la réforme des
collectivités territoriales
j'ai quand même suivi la loi Matam la
loi neutre à l'engagement on a fait
quelques-unes bon
dès lors et j'entends surtout la fin de
vos propos de l'intervention précédente
où vous dites il faut maintenant alors
traduire France ruralité qui doit se
déployer qui va se mettre en place
machin un appui au plus près des des
plus petites communes partager etc pour
formaliser pour accompagner pour aider à
l'ingénierie financière
du coup j'ai une question c'est
mais moi je m'interroge tout de même
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que les
intercos je vais le dire comme ça une
partie pas tous vous avez redonné le
chiffre des départements ne sont pas
passés à côté même j'ai envie de dire
d'un rendez-vous de l'Histoire qui
aurait pu leur permettre y compris de
renforcer leur légitimité et leur par
une meilleure reconnaissance de la
réaction qui parfois en tout cas pour
les intercos et plus vécu comme quelque
chose qui a capté le pouvoir communal
plutôt que une structure qui aurait
permis de mieux accompagner de mieux
déployer le pouvoir communal
pardon continuer avec peut-être
Catherine comme ça alors
je n'ai pas une question c'est une
remarque par rapport à ce que disait
Mathieu
on l'a mis à constaté avec ce fond vert
cette année que ça a été
extrêmement difficile pour les communes
que ça ne s'est pas très bien passé
qu'on a fait des promesses qui n'ont pas
pu être tenus on a demandé à de
nombreuses communes de transférer les
dossiers qu'ils avaient fait en novembre
en dutr sur le fond vert les dossiers
est extrêmement difficile à remplir on
les a beaucoup aidés on était alors côté
et voilà que au moment où il faut
étudier ces fonds verts il y a plus
d'argent pourquoi parce que l'enveloppe
qui a été proposée n'était pas
suffisante
et aujourd'hui on dit à ces mêmes
communes et bien écoutez on a plus
d'argent donc vous verrez ça l'année
prochaine alors qu'ils avaient fait leur
demande en dutr et qu'il en est on
aurait pu traiter ces dossiers surtout
quand il s'agit il s'agissait de
deuxième tranche donc on a mis tout le
monde en difficulté en fait ce si ce
fond vert on l'avait mis en des îles
encore je pense que ce serait beaucoup
mieux passé d'autant plus que
ceux qui ont été le plus embêté ça a été
ceux qui devaient étudier les dossiers
et notamment les sous-préfets parce que
dans les sous-préfectures certains
étaient en panique et certains même en
dépression
je peux vous le garantir parce qu'on en
a parlé donc voyez à un moment donné
tout le monde est exaspéré à la fois les
mères parce qu'il n'y arrive pas les
secrétaires de mairie parce que les
dossiers sont extrêmement compliqués les
sous préfets eux-mêmes ne savent plus à
quel sens se voué parce que on leur dit
blanc un jour et et noir le lendemain
oui il faut absolument des complexifier
la chose
un ça nous permettra aussi peut-être
d'avoir moins d'agents et moins de
personnes sur place à partir du moment
où les dossiers sont beaucoup plus
simples on a parlé de remettre
l'adhésive je pense que l'adhésif c'est
quelque chose qui doit être à la main du
sous-préfet parce que de toute façon du
préfet pardon de département parce que
de toute façon les dossiers sont traités
par les sous préfet
et en fait quand ça arrive à la région
elle a juste à signer donc quand voilà
qu'on fasse une étape de moins et qu'on
mette tout dans une simple et même
enveloppe tout simplement
après ce qui était aussi
incompréhensible pour les mères qui
habitent de façon limitrophe entre des
départements c'est que les uns vont être
vont avoir par exemple les subventions
sur leur route le voisin ne l'a pas
quelque part à un moment donné c'est
très très mal perçu et je pense qu'on
devrait avoir une politique commune en
ce qui concerne les distributions de
dutr c'est c'est difficilement
compréhensible quand on est à côté du
voisin qui lui a eu de la DUT
juste avant pour répondre à Cécile
aujourd'hui on a des départements qui se
sont organisés sur ingénierie et qui
accompagne parfaitement les
collectivités les communes le problème
c'est que c'est pas non plus sur le même
sur le territoire sur tout le territoire
de façon égalitaire on n'a pas on a des
départements on a visité ou il n'y a pas
été il n'a pas été créé l'agence
départementale et d'accompagnement des
collectivités par exemple et aujourd'hui
c'est c'est des outils qui sont
extrêmement précieux pour les mères moi
quand je viens de regarder juste là sur
le pôle juridique et
administratif de la Dax 65 des
Hautes-Pyrénées c'est plus de 700
dossiers par an de réponse au maire sur
de l'administratif sur le droit du droit
de du cimetière sur sur l'urbanisme sur
plein de dossiers c'est plus de 700
dossiers parents qui sont déposés et qui
auquel la date répond et puis de 400
dossiers d'assistance à maîtrise
d'ouvrage et là c'est le département qui
a monté cette agence là avec les
communes c'est ce format de l'agence
c'est un budget de 700 000 euros par an
quand même donc un certain moment il
faudrait aussi que l'on ait une une
équité par rapport à tous les
territoires où il n'y a pas cette
ingénierie ou les mères se retrouvent
démunis parce qu'ils ont personne pour
les accompagner
de notre comme moi je vois ce sont des
mers qui font partie de donc du bureau
de la communauté de communes qui se sont
mis en charge aujourd'hui de faire le
travail d'aller accompagner les autres
vous voyez donc
peut-être sur les différents sujets tout
d'abord sur la question d'appel à projet
là aussi les agences d'ailleurs j'y vais
depuis que je suis arrivé nous nous
avons nous l'avions pu ponctuellement
mettre dans certains partis de notre nos
interventions des logiques alors ça
plaît pas appel à projets
ça ressemble un peu quand même
voilà donc du coup nous enfin moi je en
tout cas dans les structures qui
dépendent de moi je veille je fais la
chasse à tous ces dispositifs je
considère et je les voulais indiquer y
compris sur la logique de du marché
qu'on doit être dans des logiques de
déconcentration c'est à dire que et
notre niveau de déconstration c'est le
département il y a un niveau prévu par
la loi d'animation régionale parce qu'on
a des acteurs niveau régional et qui a
du sens aussi il y a les CPR il y a des
gros objets qui sont évidemment
régionaux les sujets d'eau aussi des
agences de l'eau mais en tous les cas
sur les chutes dont on parle le
développement local en Lamaille de
choristes de cohérence d'animation de
visibilité d'action ça reste quand même
assez
utilement le département il faut donc
s'appuyer sur les préfets de département
et leur proposer effectivement le cas
des gens d'identifier le dossier
intéressant mais pas de faire la pêche
en lançant le filet et puis en fait
c'est toujours le même gros poissons qui
remonte enfin voilà donc voilà ça c'est
mon avis je l'ai aussi
c'est pour ça c'est pas le ça donc
clairement moi il faut qu'on fonctionne
différemment et dans une c'est ce que
nous on fait sur nos programmes en tout
cas sur nos logiques c'est-à-dire que on
demande au préfet qui est celui qui vous
semble si on peut pas rendre tout le
monde parce qu'on n'a pas assez ça
arrive il faut dire les choses ben
identifier nous les deux trois qui sont
les plus pertinents par rapport à cette
thématique et c'est fait localement et
il y a du coup ça se passe beaucoup
mieux sur l'agenceification alors je
suis aujourd'hui très mal placé pour
pour en faire de longs commentaires en
tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que il
faut en réduire la complexité pour les
acteurs qui en sont les bénéficiaires
les agences apportent dans leur mode de
fonctionnement les conditions
d'intervention une forme d'agilité de
souplesse il est vrai de capacité de
d'organisation rapide dont la purinité
du budget par exemple qui que ne permet
pas effectivement les structures
classiques d'État pour autant ce n'est
pas en soi un objectif ça doit être un
levier un outil donc à destination d'une
politique publique donc voilà donc
chargé aussi à nous et c'est une
démission qu'on a mais enfin on peut pas
que nous c'est de faire en sorte que les
différentes agences intervenants sur ces
questions là travaillent bien ensemble
elles sont membres du conseil
d'administration à notamment la NCT on a
des conventions cadres qu'on est en
train de reprendre je vous dis qu'il
faut qu'on arrive aussi à rendre plus
lisible d'interventions de chacun pour
que on se dise pas ah ben j'ai un sujet
sur le traitement d'une friche j'ai
quatre intervenants possibles côté état
potentiellement même mieux que ça
plusieurs types d'intervention pour un
opérateur alors ça peut répondre à des
parce que le sujet est pas le même mais
parfois c'est un peu perité
effectivement à la difficulté sur
l'enveloppe unique
alors le fond vert a amené effectivement
enfin moi je tiens souligner quand même
quelque chose le ministre bichu a
imposer une déconcentration
départementale massive
il est intervenu devant la commission
des lois je crois en fin d'année
dernière au moment du débat il me semble
vous en souvenez il a imposé ce choix
d'organisation et c'est un excellent
choix et la première ministre sera
indiquée qui aura une prolongation du
fond donc là aussi moi je dis aux
communes et vous pouvez leur dire de ma
part elles ont eu raison tant pis si
cette année ça passe pas parce qu'en
fait c'est le dossier complexe c'est
aussi qui exigent du temps pour les
préparer et elle rentreront dans le
système parce que l'année prochaine ça
passera donc le temps passé aujourd'hui
à monter le dossier il est pas perdu
c'est pas vrai c'est pas un système qui
va s'arrêter les enjeux de transition
écologique vont nous amener pendant des
années à avoir des investissements
massifs sur ces questions et clairement
tous ceux qui démarrent aujourd'hui pour
préparer leur dossier ils trouveront
leur financement sur ces champs là je
n'ai aucun doute quant à faire qu'une
seule enveloppe la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui à travers les ordotations
d'investissement vous voyez bien ce que
cherche à faire l'état enfin je sais pas
d'ailleurs c'est pas dissimulé c'est
d'orienter l'investissement des
collectivités il y a pas de voilà alors
le fond vert c'est orienté sur voilà
voilà c'est pardon alors la D alors
[Musique]
c'est tout enfin voilà c'est ça la
réalité moi je reste persuadé que pour
la gestion de ce type d'outils type de
terre la différenciation est utile parce
que il y a pas les mêmes objets les
mêmes outils les mêmes contraintes et
les mêmes demandes dans les différents
départements c'est-à-dire qu'après ça
crée pas des je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est vous êtes la commune du
département d'à côté vous dites et
pourquoi j'ai pas eu mon soutien alors
qu'à côté il l'a eu
j'allais dire si le préfet considère que
c'est ça n'a pas rentré dans la grille
d'éligibilité on voit bien comment se
positionner se positionne et commence
pas les la fameuse première réunion DETR
ou comment se sont orientés les fonds de
la des cils et aujourd'hui du
aujourd'hui du fond vert pour corréler
ce que disait Catherine belretti moi
dans mon département le fond vert on
arrive péniblement à sortir un gros
dossier qui est le syndicat des
partenaire des énergies de l'Ardèche qui
va toucher 900 000 euros
oui parce que alors c'est super bien
alors là je veux pas dire le contraire
sauf que ça montre quand même qu'il faut
être assez gros d'une taille
significative pour aller chercher du
fond vert voilà donc j'entends mais
sincèrement je
trouve quand même que ça sincèrement et
là je me base sur ce que les remontées
qu'on a eu les échanges qu'on a pu avoir
dans les différents territoires ça crée
quand même un peu de confusion et de la
complexité sur les modalités d'octroi
encore une fois parce que c'est trois
modalités d'octroi qui sont différents
encore des cils des terres on est à peu
près sur dans la même veine et et après
faut être bien imaginer que ça ne suffit
pas donc il faut aller faire des
dossiers à la région au département et
que nos élus demandent un peu
d'intelligence collective et ils se
disent si on pouvait presque essayer de
mettre tous les acteurs autour de la
table faire ce que nous disait le débat
de ce matin et peut-être se dire que
là on aurait quand même un gain
déficience qui serait qui serait assez
assez significatif ce qui n'empêche pas
encore une fois parce que je comprends
ce que vous dites
je le partage c'est c'est fond de l'État
c'est à l'état de dire où il veut les
mettre politique de relance donc il y a
pas de sujet mais je pense qu'encore une
fois sur la forme sur la déclinaison on
a vraiment un gain déficience à faire
quoi
sur le sujet bon après sur le sujet
enveloppe unique et là c'est le plutôt
côté budgétaire d'avant qui parle juste
qu'il faut toujours être prudent parce
que trois fois fait pas 3 dans des
règles budgétaires complexes de l'État
voilà
donc je ne m'arrêterai là pour parce que
je ne peux pas aller beaucoup plus loin
mais je
mais après
le Parlement le Parlement de votre
budget c'est lui qui vote budget juste
sur le le point que vous évoquez sur les
conditions d'octrodes dans mon
département moi j'ai vu un centre de
départements de fin d'organisation des
partenaires
intéressantes à savoir que les
commissions de subvention d'attribution
des subventions au niveau départemental
des Etats des cils et départements enfin
conseil départemental sont faites
ensemble
et ça c'est pertinent dans le respect de
chacun c'est à dire que j'ai eu vous
pouvez imaginer qui est tentative de
l'angleau d'un feu et en fait ça permet
une bonne répartition des et donner une
réponse en même temps pour les acteurs
qui du coup passent pas leur temps à
dire ah bah dans un mois ça va être le
département mais là c'est la commission
état et ça marche plutôt bien parce que
ça permet aussi département Etats qui
sont quand même la plupart du temps
assez en organisés qui voit bien le bon
dossier puis le dossier qu'il faut
retravailler donc peuvent avoir une
parole unique qui peut être bien perçue
et se permet de régler un sens dessus
donc ça c'est une approche positive
c'est surtout aussi pour pour ne pas
avoir des conflits de montant de
subventions en fait je sais que sur des
Hautes-Pyrénées ça se pratique mais ça
se pratique de façon un peu empirique
avec la bonne volonté du
sous-préfet et du préfet et des
conseillers départementaux puisque c'est
avec le Conseil départemental pour pour
pas arriver un taux de subvention de 90%
et que la commune après elle soit elle
se voit retirée la subvention qu'elle
avait espéré donc c'est des questions
aussi mais ça c'est quelque chose qu'il
faudrait peut-être arriver aussi un
certain moment un généraliser et c'est
ce qu'on faisait avec avec les contrats
de pays bon c'est vrai que ces fameux
pays créés avec la loi voilée ou on
s'est retrouvé avec les trois entités
états région départements sur des
contrats de pays où chacun avait sa
propre ses propres enveloppes mais on
avait un comité de pilotage et où chacun
disait bon mais moi sur cet endroit là
je mets ça
c'était c'était pas et ça on a perdu
cette culture là aussi de la
contractualisation avec les les entités
les collègues les autres financeurs que
sont la Région Département
juste pour finir les réponses et
peut-être sur ça alors on a le CRPE qui
doit pouvoir peut-être dans une vague et
dans une phase 2 être aussi un moyen de
fonctionner un peu comme ça d'être un
lieu
moins peut-être formaliste de
contractualisation fermée définitive de
projet on est dedans on n'est pas dedans
ce qui crée un énorme on serait sur le
terrain ça on le sait mais plutôt une
méthode de travail collectif avec le
département la région éventuellement sur
la base d'un bassin de vie souvent ça
correspond aux anciens pays Petr pour
voir les projets et voir comment on peut
les accompagner je pense que c'est on a
possibilité de retrouver un peu la
logique que vous évoquiez sur la
présence d'État différenciés sur les
territoires où je rejoins beaucoup
notamment sur la réflexion sur la
ruralité que l'on a la ministre fort
porte beaucoup ça sur l'idée que il y a
on va dire franchement il y a pas besoin
de une personne par département il y a
des départements c'est pas nécessaire on
peut trouver d'autres moyens des
départements très urbanisés ou certes il
peut y avoir un espace rural mais on
peut trouver à travers l'agglomération à
travers les effectifs de l'État qui sont
parfois un peu plus denses des solutions
en revanche on a des départements ou
concrètement et là ça rejoint le point
que vous évoquez sur est-ce que il y a
quelque chose qu'on a raté moi je crois
pas qu'on est raté quelque chose mais on
a des réalités objectives aussi c'est
qu'il y a quand même des communautés de
communes qui sont très petites très
faibles et sans et sans être réservé et
qui ont du mal à recruter des gens d'un
certain niveau parce que elles sont
enclavées peu attractives en déclin
démographique parfois enfin je veux pas
faire un paysage un trou noir enfin il y
a des fois c'est quand même accumul vous
avez aussi parfois des départements qui
sont pas forcément très fringants non
plus parce qu'ils sont confrontés aussi
à des problématiques d'équilibre
d'opérations parce que en fait il y a
beaucoup de demandes donc c'est pas
voilà c'est pas tout le monde tout le
monde n'était pas au même complètement
au même niveau au point de départ et
donc c'est quand même bien normal qu'il
y a des endroits où on se dise
aujourd'hui qu'on va aller l'accompagner
la commune non pas contre la communauté
de communes mais parce que la Communauté
de Communes n'est pas suffisamment
équipée pour vous accompagner peut-être
ce projet-là et surtout pas contre la
Communauté de Communes c'est avec la
communauté de communes ça doit se faire
dans une logique collective mais on
vient donner le coup de main sur un bout
du territoire on a des communautés vous
savez à 40 parfois 40 communes
Communauté de Communes elle a peut-être
une priorité qui correspond qui peut pas
et puis il y a d'autres projets sur le
reste du territoire qui peut pas être
accompagné parce que c'est une question
de moyens de capacité d'ingénierie donc
c'est là où on peut venir apporter une
réponse sur un projet sur un projet dans
sous-ensemble de cette intercommunalité
et puis les départements je pense que
ils trouveront aussi et certains
aujourd'hui dans la réflexion sur ce
programme en parle de s'organiser
ensemble parce que là où l'État par
exemple met un appui le département
pourrait sur un autre arrondissement un
autre secteur mettre un appui aussi et
puis on se répartit un peu les moyens ça
coûte entre guillemets moins cher à
chacun parce que mais voilà on fait une
politique coordonnée je sens qu'il y a
un niveau de maturité élevé aujourd'hui
sur les territoires sur ces questions là
et que et que je pense qu'on peut y
arriver ça marchera peut-être pas à
certains endroits mais je pense voilà et
qu'on peut arriver à se dire écoutez
l'état il va aller là et là en soutient
sur tel et tel département vous allez là
et là tout le monde est content et puis
ça permet de faire avancer un certain
nombre de territoires qui se sentent
encore parfois aujourd'hui un peu oublié
très bien merci beaucoup je pense que
vous avez reçu notre questionnaire aussi
vous pourrez nous nous adresser les
réponses et merci en tout cas monsieur
directeur général et à la prochaine
audition et tout au moins nos prochains
conseils d'administration de la CCT
merci merci cher collègue